So it’s lithium. Lithium is the top of the
alkali metals, the lightest of all of them.
It is very, very reactive, we use it a lot
in organic chemistry, to activate carbon,
carbon-bond formation, but as you can see
here it is a very, very dark coloured metal.
It is actually very really and shiny if you
cut it fresh, but it reacts with nitrogen
in the air to form lithium nitride, really,
really quite quickly.
So, lithium is the lightest metal. It is a
very light element. It will float on water,
though of course, it does react with water
as well.
So we are going to take a small sample, and
again we are going to see what happens when
we react it with water, ok.
It has had a number of quite important applications
in the last few years. Some of you will know
that lithium is used for treating what is
now called bipolar disorder or manic depression.
The lithium itself is stored under oil, to
stop it reacting with the air and also with
water, so we are just going to just clean
off all the oil now before popping it into
a sample of water.
And in fact, I think, although I am not a
great expert on pop songs, there is at least
one pop song called Lithium based on this.
So here we have the dried lithium, which you
can see is this metal and we are going to
drop it into the water and let’s see what
happens.
And it’ll fizz around a little bit. So you
see the lithium reacting quite rapidly with
the water and you can see hydrogen gas being
evolved, now if we catch that hydrogen gas
in a beaker or in a test tube we can then
ignite it or burn it.
But lithium is very reactive, one of my colleagues
said that if you have a fire with lithium
you can never put it out.
You can see freshly cut lithium there nice
shiny metal, but as it reacts with the nitrogen
it forms a nitride, which is black.
It reacts with nitrogen in the air it is one
of the few metals that will react with nitrogen
spontaneously, so that if you have a container
of lithium, which has been exposed to air,
it tends to smell of ammonia because it has
reacted with nitrogen and then the water in
the air reacts with the salt that is formed
and you get a smell of ammonia, so it smells
a bit like dirty nappies.